hey y'all it's betsy from happily ever
after etc and i am back with another
gardening video so today i have a few
things to plant
not a lot but i figured might as well
pop out here
and talk about it just a little bit so
the first two things
i have to plant are some more of these
really pretty blue
lobelias so they are smaller they only
get six to 12 inches tall but they do
get pretty wide and i picked up two more
one here
and one down there for the new garden
bed
when i first got these i think i got one
two three four five of them
um
and i really liked them but i went back
to get some more for this bed they were
sold out so
went back this week and they had some
more i was very excited so i grabbed
a one
for all the way down at the end i needed
just one more down there and
two
for this garden bed to just kind of tie
it all together and give it that short
little fun front layer that i needed in
a few places so we're gonna pop those in
and then i'm going to be planting some
proven winners
truffle of pink gomprina
so i will put a picture up on the screen
[Music]
of what these look like i grew them last
year
right in here you can see i'll show you
up close i have one coming back i
planted four now these babies get like
two to almost three feet tall and wide
and they they take a little bit to start
going like maybe mid-june mid-july they
really start to put on growth and then
they just explode so i like to
interplant them
um well i say i like like i've done it a
million times
last year i had the idea that i would
interplant them
with my fox glove
because the fox glove only blooms in the
spring you can see it is
it is not done there are definitely
still
new sims new socks coming up
but it is a spring flowering plant it is
a biannual so it only comes up and
blooms once every two year then you
plant you plant new ones for next year
and so i do have two of those growing in
that will bloom for me next year and i'm
going to be planning some more of the
camelot mix next year which holds in its
first year but regardless whichever type
you have
first year second year
whatever year they only bloom in the
spring
and sometimes very early summer they do
not bloom all summer long um and so
i love this little spot with my sweet
little
bird bath and those long tall spikes
behind my lower layers and so
the gomphrena that doesn't start really
putting on exploding growth until june
or july is perfect i interpret it with
the fox gloves and they are also a tall
pink airy spike kind of flower and so as
the fox gloves fade out the vampirina
really starts to take over and i always
have that beautiful tall pink element
in that mid layer of my garden bed here
on this here i'll have the glass behind
it so that'll be even prettier but i'm
very excited so my mom actually went and
just picked those up
i am at home because i have to go every
30 minutes and check on our new puppies
cinnamon if you guys have been watching
me i've had cinnamon with me glued to my
hip for the last like two weeks she
finally had her puppies so they are
resting inside they're not old enough to
come out here yet but i can't leave the
house for a while because
i have to be on puppy watch so
mom went to get the grandparent and as
soon as she gets here we will pop those
in the ground and i will show them off
to you but right now i'm gonna stop
talking i'm gonna put these two lobelias
in the ground and get them watered in
[Music]
coming together y'all
all right y'all the truffula pink
gumprina is here i'm so excited i
absolutely loved these last year so they
are like
little pink cotton candy puff balls
the pollinators love them
that they wanted
and they are just so pretty and they
really like once they get going they
fill in and they were a massive presence
right here behind my little
bird bath
so
um mom went and got these like i said
she got 18 of them
10 for her i asked for eight
so i will show you exactly how i'm going
to put them in here
over here
right down there
i have my one that came back from last
year now these are annuals they are not
perennials i'm not sure why that one
came back the other three didn't
i think it's because it's just closest
to the porch and it was really protected
and i am down here in alabama 8b almost
florida so i do think
that maybe if i cut these back to the
ground next year and i really want to
make a wreath out of these because i
have seen so many people do dried
gumprina wreaths and they're beautiful
so i really want to harvest a bunch this
year
and make a big wreath so that will give
me some motivation
cut them back to the ground i'm going to
mulch over them and we'll just see if
they come back
all of them next year so i'm gonna put
four in right here so again they fill in
amongst the fox glove and then i think
i'm gonna put four more down on the
other side i really liked these last
year and i wanted them in more places in
my garden so i'm going to put them down
um in front of some of my iris that are
also about to be out of bloom and
hopefully these will do well on that
side as well it'll also be a bit of an
experiment because these are definitely
full sun plants
this spot gets a lot of sun it doesn't
get quite as much down there um i have
my peonies down there because they need
less sun so i do think these will do
okay down there i don't think they'll
get as big so it's going to be a bit of
an experiment to see
how they do in other parts of my garden
maybe next year i'll put them even more
places
i don't know but like you saw on the top
they are um 22 to 28 tall
spacing is a minimum of 12 to 18 inches
they get
well that's the width um they are
annuals except for end zones 9a to 11b
and hearty down to 30 degrees
they do say you want to fertilize them
for best results so i will start to
fertilize them
and
full sun
dead deadheading not necessary drought
tolerant heat tolerant i mean these guys
are workhorses so
let's go ahead and place them and see
what we think
[Music]
so
i definitely want one
right here
kind of
right behind the little girl
and then i think i want one on either
[Music]
that's definitely
12 to 18 inches
[Music]
i think that's better
that'll give me more about 18 inches
trying not to fall over
crush anything
[Music]
that was a bug it was my own hair
okay
so that's what i'm going to do so you
can see
the fox club are clint in a triangle
and i've just flipped that over and made
a reverse triangle with the gomphrena
that way
as the fox glove are going away the
gomphrena are coming up
i do need one more over there
[Music]
oh
i have a fox glove right here and i have
this hydrangea right here so
it kind of makes it a little hard
to put this exactly 12 to 18 inches i
don't want it to crowd the hydrangea
either
but
i think that's good
i am going to go ahead
pop down to the other side and see where
i want to place these for because
if
there is a better spot for five over
there then i might just stick with four
on this side and do five over there so
give me two seconds
[Music]
okay y'all so i'm definitely gonna move
this one
down there i have spots for five of them
down kind of behind my panties i just
planted two peony plants
um and it is their first year they are
not going to flower this year they're
going to grow big and beautiful and
hopefully next year we'll have blooms
but they're pretty little this year
and you need to leave quite a bit of air
around candies check out my video that i
did i'm still learning but i did a lot
of research on how to grow candies in
south because it is hard
and i got a lot of good tips from other
people so i want to share them with all
of you
but you need a lot of air there's so
many maps
eat a lot of air
around your peonies when they're fully
grown and so there is a lot of space
around them right now that they do not
need this year
but they will need in um
the new year the year after that in the
next couple years as they grow so
filling that space with annuals is not
necessary
but it is a good way to still have color
in that space that will eventually be
filled with beautiful peonies and this
year can be filled with beautiful gum
free so
we'll stop talking about it we're going
to put these babies in the ground
got my gloves
i've got my little shovel this area is
pretty tilled up i um i planted here
last year and i used my auger to really
aerate the soil before i planted this
here
so i'm going to try to use my little
spade so as not to disturb
the roots of the things already growing
i do not
want to hurt the fox gloves or the
hydrangea or anything else that i have
in here especially my fox gloves that i
have going for next year because
then i've started at ground zero all
over
also i need new gloves i love these but
i have literally
literally more holes in them
all right
i'm gonna be careful cause i do have a
couple seeds in here that still haven't
germinated
they might not they might be dead but
i'm hoping they'll still come up
they're also for fox club so
eventually i want this whole
area to be full of foxglove as well as
over there just popping out of the back
border with the gladiolus and the iris
but
oxford expensive i bought a bunch of
seats to start for next year i'm going
to start them inside
like a real gardener
[Music]
and you're just buying things at the big
box store
or at your local nursery which is where
i got these three
i actually have not seen a single
fox glove at a big box store this year
i've been looking so i wanted to get
some more inexpensive ones
haven't seen any
these i all bought from dolphin
nurseries which is my favorite local
nursery
here in the area check them out
um
other two the white ones that are almost
done
i got from
buzz and blossom's nursery which is
actually
i believe owned by the same family
they're a little rebound so let's just
tease them
yes
[Music]
that was literally perfect
i don't know if you were supposed to cut
these back as you plant them like you
are with some other things like um
petunias or verbena i'm not going to
because i still want to enjoy the fox
gloves so i definitely don't want the
comprehensive start growing like mad yet
they shouldn't they need heat
to really grow
but
you know if i should cut them back or
not leave a comment down below
[Music]
foreign
definitely saving these because i have
eight of them mom has ten
and they both came with trays
and
does that look this look like the
perfect size pot
to plant a fox glove seedling up into to
grow
before i transplant it to the garden
right it does
[Music]
so
see how these have the little pink balls
and these have the pink spires they're
very similar
[Music]
of course they're not bells
there aren't multiple spires but you
know
they're pretty close
[Music]
gonna get these
it is literally the end of the day
shadiest part possible but
still human and alafrica mammal
and get these babies watered in go pop
the other five in and i'm gonna call it
a day
i am hot
[Music]
all right y'all i have my three little
truffle pinks here
and another two here behind this peony
and behind this peony i also moved
the begonias up so all these begonias
were here last year
and for some reason they're coming back
so
i'm just gonna let them do their thing
and we'll see how they do but you saw i
had to pull out some old landscaping
fabric
i put it in last year when i did the
border
and it was to suppress all the grass but
the grass is definitely dead under there
and it was starting to inhibit the
growth of some of these things
you cut a hole for your plant but i
would notice at least with the begonias
they weren't growing through properly
the bigger rooted things were fine so
i've just been pulling it from around
the begonias and hopefully they will
fill in better this year but
there's that truffula pink it should
give us a nice mid layer there once all
these iris are done
and back there as well we'll see how
they do over here since it's not as
sunny but
in the meantime let's pop over here real
quick and i will show you
up close the other ones and we will be
done
all right
you can see that baby truffle of pink
there
and there and whoop one right there so
this is the one right here in front of
this box club it's coming back from last
year
they're not too different of a size so
we will just see how this area fell down
but i gotta go take care of cinnamon and
those puppies so i'll see y'all later
bye
[Music]
you